glass concludes the M night Shyamalan
superhero trilogy that began with them
breakable at the star of the millennium
as has become a signature with Schemmel
am there are a lot of twists and turns
and throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the film and its ending
there will of course be heavy spoilers
here I mean this is the guy who they had
to invent the spoiler alert for so if
you don't want to know anything about
the movie then I highly suggest that you
turn off now but for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I rune it so you don't
have to the film centers around mr.
glass played by samuel l.jackson
manipulating david dunn now known as the
overseer into facing off against Kevin
Wendell Crum otherwise known as the
whole class wants the world to finally
accept that people with superhuman
abilities exist this is due to a number
of rising phenomena that makes it clear
that there are superhumans are modest
whilst the general public believes this
to merely be a psychological condition
glass cone [ __ ] a showdown between the
beast and overseer with the three
meeting somewhere where the eyes of the
world are on there after they escaped
the insane asylum in which they have
been denounced they go to a building for
a face-off against each other
of course glass is known for his
terrorist attacks in unbreakable so
getting them to a location where they
think that there may be danger isn't too
difficult for him we learn in the film
that class has the ability to look at
blueprints and instantly learn
everything about the ins and outs of a
structure which is why he was so
talented at placing bombs and
destructive devices in unbreakable using
the skill at glasses rigged a building
with cameras that will capture the epic
faceoff so that the world cannot deny
this Superman's existence juxtaposing
this we learn of a secret society of
people that wish to put an end to the
super-powered individuals no matter
whether they are good
glass wishes to expose both them and the
superhero phenomena so that the world
can no longer deny them which this
showdown delivers upon in the end
unfortunately all three characters die
however their sacrifices are not in vain
with the world finally realizing that
those with incredible abilities exist we
see KC cook David's son and mr. glasses
mother meet and discuss how though some
of their deeds may have been evil and by
some of them I obviously mean glass and
the hoard but in the end they were
justifiable due to the revelations that
they brought forward overlooking the
whole terrorism and mass murderer thing
that glass and Kevin did it's clear that
they have a point somewhat and that
people with abilities will now no longer
be ignored or chastise say as they would
have been in something like the x-men
universe overall I can see why glasses
getting mixed reviews as there are a lot
of elements that contradict the prior
films and even this movie itself has
some things that just don't gel KC
siding with crumb makes little sense
especially for those who have seen split
and the whole there are a lot of things
that don't feel fully developed I
remember when it was announced back in
2000 that unbreakable was originally
meant to be part of a trilogy and after
waiting 20 years for the finale of it I
feel slightly disappointed for every
amazing moment it seems like there is an
equally bad one and there were just some
things that don't seem to fit together
whilst those already fully invested into
the universe will have a lot of fun here
and it does tease a larger universe to
come
I don't know how enjoyable it will be
especially with the three most
interesting characters and now dead
obviously we will see down the line but
to me it just falls flat slightly so
what are your thoughts on the ending of
glass and where would you like to see
the universe go from here
would you prefer a prequel of them to
just scrap the entire thing comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my recent ending
explain breakdown for replicas which
will be linked at the end this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hits
scribe thanks again for taking the time
to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]